I'm shaking so hard right now um I have
to start by thanking my first believers
my parents and my little sister Katie my
mother and my dad they both have have
believed in me since day one and not
everybody gets to have that and I'm very
grateful to have that Meagan beat jess
moskaluke three-year winning streak in
the female artist of the year category
and she won Sirius XM's rising star
awards just try and enjoy each moment
and soak it in and recognize that some
of these moments are once-in-a-lifetime
things and and it just always be
grateful for where I'm at and not be too
hard on myself so this weekend I'm
enjoying that also enjoying himself
before the show country superstar Brett
Kissel my pregame routine is put on some
socks that are gonna represent the show
and try and dress up in your very best
I'm very lucky that I got to bring my
little girls with me my beautiful wife
on their very first green carpet
experience so because it is the Canadian
Country Music Awards check these bad
boys out Brett brought his sock a game
and snagged two awards video of the year
and male artist of the year
miss recognition in this honor might be
the best one in the world so thank you
so much to think that my name to be
honest it's gonna be beside some of my
heroes a guy like Paul Brant got like
Charley major guys like Dean Brody that
is very special as I'm I don't take for
granted another big winner Dean won the
Apple music fans Choice Award I just
want to keep making music for my fans
you know and there's that pressure
that's always inside of me that I want
to stick around I want to be involved in
these people's lives for as long as I
can and yep that's Blake Shelton
presenting Dean's award the voice coach
also graced his Canadian fans with a
little special performance
[Music]
then there was Dallas Smith winning top
honors for album of the year and single
of the year the awards are great and
being able to get up and thank people
that support you is a huge thing for me
importance for me but I gotta remember
that when you lose it doesn't really
matter it's about the fans when you win
it all so it's great but you got to
remember that too right it's about the
fans